- [Mark] Alright, Matt and Megan.
Where are you guys,
where are you guys from, originally?
- [Matt] I'm originally
from Indianapolis, Indiana.
- [Megan] And Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
- [Mark] Pittsburgh. And,
how was your childhood?
You had both parents, one parent?
- Yeah, I,
grew up in a very nice family.
Both my parents are still married.
I have a younger brother.
You know,
I had both sets of
grandparents growing up.
Pretty much was able to do whatever,
you know, I wanted to do.
- [Mark] You had a great childhood.
- Yes, absolutely.
Played sports, played
hockey my whole life.
My brother played hockey,
traveled a lot as a family.
So yeah, it was a really good childhood.
- [Mark] Megan how about you?
- Yeah same, I have both
parents also still married.
I have a huge family, actually.
Eight brothers and
three sisters.
(Megan chuckles)
Yeah. Suburban area.
Yeah.
I graduated high school.
- [Mark] And how did you
guys end up down here?
This is like,
this is the the opposite
of the spectrum from
your childhood.
- That's a good question.
We ask ourselves that every day.
- Yeah.
Well...
- [Mark] Is there
addiction in your family?
- No, there's not.
- I mean, they drink a little bit, but
not so much, like, you know.
- Yeah. There's no drug use in my family.
Maybe a little bit of alcohol, but,
nothing with drugs.
- [Mark] When did you guys
first get into using drugs?
- At a very,
at a very young age for me.
At
like
12.
I was introduced to just like alcohol,
but around my freshman
year of high school,
So like 14,
I was introduced to pills and
marijuana,
and more alcohol.
(Matt coughs)
And then it just kind of
progressed from there.
My sophomore year,
I started doing a lot of cocaine
and,
ecstasy in my junior year.
(Matt clearing throat)
And then,
I was actually sent to
boarding school my senior
year of high school,
all the way out in Utah.
And, when I came back from Utah,
that's when I was introduced
to heroin for the first time.
- Mine was more so after high school,
I always smoked pot.
No during high school, but
never really anything hardcore.
Yeah, after high school, it
was pills obviously first.
And then, heroin.
- [Mark] And was it your heroin addiction
that got you guys together?
Is that how you met?
- Yeah, so,
we both came out here
for rehab.
We both came out here...
- To Orange County.
- Yeah, to Orange County first, for rehab.
And
I,
I went through...
- [Mark] Coming from Indiana and...
- Yeah, they flew,
they flew us,
both out here.
They, you know,
fly you out here.
- Not knowing each other yet.
- Yeah we didn't know each other yet,
but they paid for everything,
you know, beautiful places,
like nice rehabs.
And I kind of bounced from
one to another, to another.
And,
I was in the middle of a relapse,
when I met Megan.
And Megan was still in treatment
when I met her.
So. Yeah.
- [Mark] And what are you
guys doing for money now?
You're living on the
street, in a tent, right?
- Yeah. We live in a tent.
- [Mark] Yeah. What do you do for money?
- Boosting.
- Yeah. We boost, we steal.
- From stores.
- Yeah.
Our parents send us
money every now and then.
- [Mark] Your parents
know you're out here?
- Our parents know that
we're in California,
in Los Angeles, but not that we're
living in a tent.
My, both of our parents would be
absolutely horrified to...
- They wouldn't believe it.
- Yeah, they wouldn't
even believe it, honestly.
Both of our parents are kind of aware that
we're not doing exactly
what we're supposed to,
but, you know,
they don't know the severity of it.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] What does your addiction
cost you in like a week?
- I,
so we,
about two months ago switched
from,
- Longer than that.
- About three or four months ago?
About three or four months
ago, we switched from
heroin to Fentanyl.
So we do straight Fentanyl
now, not any heroin.
And Fentanyl is a lot more expensive.
And so we probably
spend 150 to $200 a day.
- [Mark] What's the difference in terms
of the high that you get from Fentanyl?
- It's basically the same high,
except Fentanyl is
much, much more dangerous
and a lot more lethal,
a lot more potent.
They say Fentanyl is like 10
times stronger than heroin.
So,
we actually both got off using a needle,
because of doing Fentanyl.
Because we don't have to shoot it anymore,
but...
- [Mark] Do you smoke it?
- Yeah. We smoke it.
So that's kind of a good thing, but,
yeah, you get, you know,
very drowsy or, you're not off,
you know.
Because of our tolerance we sometimes
really gain energy from it.
But yeah, we usually spend
around 150 to $200 a day on,
on Fentanyl.
- [Mark] Is it for the pair
of you or for each of you?
- Yeah, no. For the,
for the both of us.
Basically it's the same
routine every single day,
living down here, we wake up,
we hopefully still have
drugs leftover from the night before.
You know, we do what we can to stay well.
And then we go to work.
And work being, we go boost.
Because we don't have a car or anything,
we have to use public
transportation, which,
you know,
takes the majority of the time,
your time.
So we spend like, you
know, six to eight hours
out boosting and getting money,
cashing that,
that merchandise in.
And then we
go pick up,
and go back to our tent,
and get high.
It's the same thing every single day.
- [Mark] Who do you
sell the merchandise to?
- We sell it to different people.
- [Mark] There,
there are people who will pay...
- Yeah.
So, out in Los Angeles,
it's not like this where I'm from,
or where she's from,
but there's, you know,
there's a lot of people out here.
There's a lot of
different opportunities out here.
Whether that be good opportunities
or bad opportunities.
And,
you know, you can basically
do a wide variety of things to get money.
And so there's
also a wide variety of
people that are willing to
cash in on
your addiction,
basically, you know?
And so you have a lot of
kids out here that are
addicted to drugs that
do whatever they have to
to get high every day and stay well.
And there's people out there that
take advantage of that.
And so,
yeah, there's,
not just one or two, there's many, many
many people that buy
the merchandise out here.
- [Mark] Now, being a
white couple on the street,
you're, almost like a target
for a lot of
people in this neighborhood.
- Yeah, for sure.
- [Mark] Have you experienced...
When we first got down here,
you know we,
didn't know anybody.
Obviously being young and white,
were very much targeted.
They automatically assume
we have a lot of money.
They automatically assume that
they pretty much can
manipulate us in any way,
to get what they want out of us.
So when we first moved down here,
we were introduced to a guy,
and,
he,
basically
was
helping us,
you know,
he let us stay in his tent
with him for about a month.
He was,
you know,
getting us by every day.
(loud Mexican music coming from outside)
And we,
because we were so new, we weren't
we didn't know the ulterior motives behind
him doing that.
And so, we thought
he was just a good guy,
and being naive, you know,
people that we were at first,
we continued to let him help us.
And, when we decided to leave him,
like leave living with him.
He got very, very upset.
He said, we owed him money.
And so he came
and found us,
was very, very angry,
he was yelling and had a giant metal pole
and actually hit Megan
like three or four times
with the metal pole.
And then when I came back,
he was still yelling and screaming,
and he hit me a few times,
but we ultimately had to pay $500 to
get out of this situation.
- He extorted us.
And that's not
an uncommon thing down here, you know?
And,
luckily,
I was able to get that kind of money.
My parents were very,
worrisome,
and wondering why I needed so much money,
but, we did get the money,
we got through it.
And ever since then, we've been a lot more
alert and aware of everything
going on around us.
And so luckily we haven't
let that come in between us.
You know...
- [Mark] How old are you guys?
- [Matt] Both of us just turned 29.
- [Mark] Have you been
in jail for boosting
or any other thing?
- [Matt] Yeah. I,
I actually,
I've been to jail twice
since we've been down here.
The first time I went to jail for 19 days.
And then the second
time I went to jail for,
like, a month.
And she was but...
(Megan whispering)
- [Matt] That was first time...
- And she was, she was out
here by herself both times,
you know, which is very, very
scary for me.
Because I know
what she has to deal with every day.
And also when I go to jail
and my mind clears up from all
the drugs and everything else
you start to see how
crazy
the life that we live really is.
You know, neither of us grew up this way.
We've never known anything like this.
And so,
we start to normalize
the things that happened down here and,
and the lives we live.
But,
when I went to jail
and my mind cleared up,
it kind of dawned on me how
crazy and how pathetic, you know,
things really are.
- [Matt] Megan, do you
ever have conversations
with Matt about,
like, what the fuck are we doing?
- Of course.
Every day almost.
Yeah.
- Yeah, we have,
we have conversations almost
every single day about,
wanting,
wanting to get out of here,
and try and get out of here.
- You just get stuck, you know?
Yeah
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah. It's,
when we probably, within our first week
when we first got down here.
This old man was crossing, older guy,
he was probably in his fifties,
was crossing the street,
and he said something to us and he said,
don't get stuck down here.
You know, that happened to me.
I've been down here for 27 years.
And it didn't really dawn
on me at the time, but,
you know, that is what kind of gets...
What kind of happens.
Because you get in such a
cycle, in such a routine,
and,
it's just,
every day is the same.
It doesn't matter whether it's
Monday, Tuesday, Christmas,
it's all the same and,
it's just hard to break.
- [Mark] So do you guys have
any plans for your future?
- Yeah. So,
we've been talking a lot about
leaving California,
and going back,
most likely to Pittsburgh
where she's from.
And,
kind of building a future there.
You know, we've kind of realized
that it's very expensive out here.
It's hard to
get by.
And so we've been thinking
about for quite a while,
that we would want to
move back to Pittsburgh to
kind of stay with her family
and build a future there.
So when we first started dating,
not first but,
we always talked about getting pregnant.
I,
you know, I've been in love
with Megan for a long time.
We've talked about kids.
I know that she would be a great mother.
She has a lot of siblings,
a lot of nieces and nephews.
But when we were on heroin,
she could never get pregnant.
And it just never happened.
And then,
about three months ago,
she started, you know,
throwing up in the morning,
feeling very sick in
the morning, every day,
you know, and just having
other symptoms.
- That's when we transit...
Like, transferred to...
- Yeah. That's when, that's
right after we transitioned
from heroin to Fentanyl, so,
her body was off heroin and...
- Not shooting up.
- Yeah, not shooting up.
And,
so we found out she was pregnant.
- [Mark] How far are you?
- Like four and a half months.
- [Mark] Four and a half months?
Have you seen doctors about it?
- Mhm.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah, and,
it's one of those things where,
you kinda,
you know,
I think it was scary for the both of us,
you know.
And also,
it kind of,
it's just an even bigger
reminder every day of
why we need to put action
to what we're saying.
But even at that, even
because of the pregnancy,
it's still sometimes isn't enough
to get us out of this cycle.
And...
- [Mark] Looking at all the women
that have been here with kids.
- Yeah.
It's very, very hard.
It's
very hard to...
- It's hard to accept that,
I could be one of those people, you know.
- And especially just
because you know, like
sober neither one of us are those people,
but,
it's,
on drugs
it's just another,
it's another story.
And it's not an, it's not an excuse.
And we both know what we're doing is
not the right thing.
And,
even I know as a man, I
I should be stepping up and doing more,
but,
you know we both just
kind of find ourselves in
that cycle, dude.
And it
it's sad,
honestly, it's sad and
it hurts really bad.
- [Mark] Alright. Good luck
to you in future, you guys.
And to your child.
- [Megan] Thanks.